all right so I'm going to talk about how
to never have another cavity again and
this information is definitely should be
applied to your children as well so you
might want to let your kids watch it I
have a lot of experience in this topic
because every single tooth that's
attached to my skull had a cavity at one
time unfortunately I wish I would have
had this information back then okay now
the derivation of the word cavity comes
from the Latin word which means to Decay
I mean it's bizarre to me that a person
would have decay in this enamel tooth
which is harder than steel I mean to
have Decay at an early age is crazy I
mean what's going on here it's very
abnormal so to figure this out we need
to go to the experts the American Dental
Association okay so what they say is
that sugary food okay left on your teeth
uh our food for bacteria that thrive on
the sugar that then make acids and to
prevent this you must brush your teeth
okay brush your teeth and floss your
teeth very important and also see the
dentist on a regular basis and they do
say to limit snacking okay that's good
advice and a well-balanced meal okay
well that's good advice well the
question is what is the definition of a
well-balanced meal of course definition
also includes
whole grains and they also recommend
fluoride treatments toothpaste with
fluoride and also Dental sealants can be
used and that's like a plastic coating
around your teeth that will definitely
protect the tooth from these acids and
also to keep the added sugar to a
minimum all right well okay good advice
an interesting story I don't know if you
heard about this the sugar industry
created an organization long ago called
the international sugar Research
Foundation it's kind of like a PR group
for the industry and apparently recently
the 300 documents that were found in the
basement of I think some University okay
that were meeting notes and documents
from this sugar Industry Group and in
these documents they found some very
interesting information that there is
some collusion with the National
Institute of dental health and they came
up with a plan to suppress the link
between consuming sugar and getting
cavities back some decades ago so they
wanted to instead push the fluoride the
dental sealants also research and doing
tooth decay vaccines and they should
focus more on the fat okay fat is the
cause of a lot of these problems not the
sugar I'm not sure if you knew about
that but that's some interesting data so
it is true that sugar and starch starch
would be like rice grains corn things
like that you know stuff like the breads
the pasta the cereal crackers biscuits
waffles pancakes all that those are
those are starches as well as sugars but
the sugar in the starch
is really good food for acid forming
bacteria in your mouth and so these
bacteria start to ferment these sugars
and starches okay they ferment it and as
a byproduct uh you get all these
different acids now what's interesting
about just fermentation in general
cancer gets their fuel from fermentation
which is interesting so they literally
change their um way of getting energy to
fermenting sugar and carbs which is
actually very very interesting that
cancer uses fermentation someone with
restless leg syndrome that's consuming a
lot of sugar and starches is going to
have a good amount of fermentation as
well as a deficiency of vitamin B1 so in
other words when you feed your body a
lot of starch sugar the requirement for
vitamin B1 goes way up because you need
B1 to metabolize all this sugar and of
course I was the poster your child for
restless leg syndrome when I was in my
early 30s I would get up in the middle
of night and just literally pound my
thighs because I had so much energy in
them little did I know it was that Ben
and Jerry's before I would go to bed and
all these other carbs
I was creating this excessive
fermentation and this severe B1
deficiency which aggravates your nervous
system big time now regarding cancer I
think what happens too is consuming a
lot of sugar and refined carbs can
damage the mitochondria okay that could
potentially lead to cancer that's one
mechanism and then you have another
interesting
um
fermentation problem in your small
intestine when you get too much bacteria
in your small intestine and it should be
in the large intestine but if it's in
the small intestine you're going to get
excessive amount of fermentation and
you're going to end up with a severe B1
deficiency a magnesium deficiency and a
zinc deficiency because these microbes
are going to eat up those nutrients so
the requirement for those nutrients goes
way up when you're getting this
fermentation problem in your gut the
only reason I'm bringing this up is
because it's interesting to look at
these other problems with fermentation
throughout the body we need normal
fermentation in the large bowel but we
don't need this excessive fermentation
in other parts of the body including in
our mouth now there is some protection
in our mouth against this problem
there's this enzyme called Thailand
which the p is silent but it's
pronounced Thailand which is is
basically an enzyme called amylase that
helps break down the starch and it will
inhibit these acids from being produced
and generating cavities but it's
dependent on the B vitamins especially
B1 which is another interesting point
and the more carbs you eat the more
you're going to be deficient and deplete
this enzyme and the more acid the less
this enzyme can be activated it needs to
be activated in like a neutral pH or
slightly alkaline and so you can even
get like a little pH tester and just put
it in your mouth and see where your pH
is if it's below seven then chances are
this enzyme is not going to actually
work and there's other things in your
saliva that can help neutralize the acid
you have this sodium bicarbonate which
is baking soda your body actually makes
that to help neutralize the acid so
there's all these different things that
people do to try to minimize tartar
control to try to minimize these acids
these acid forming bacteria by taking
baking soda brushing your teeth with
baking soda doing fluoride treatments
tooth sealants all these things are just
the tip of the iceberg they're not the
underlying costs throughout cavities you
just have to get rid of the sugar out of
the diet you have to get rid of the
starches you have to get your kids off
these sugars and starches so many people
have this idea that going on a low carb
diet doing the ketogenic diet is just
for people that are overweight it's not
really for people that are thin like
children no it actually is and so I
wanted to just take this example of
cavities and relate that to sugar and
carbohydrates just to increase the need
to go on a ketogenic diet and I also
think your kids should go on the
ketogenic plan not necessarily
intermittent fasting but definitely
ketogenic foods and the prevention of
cavities is just one good reason to do
it now to learn about the ketogenic diet
to know how to do it you should watch
this video I put up right here